if you're unhappy with PlayStation Plus  is free game offerings sony has a plan  to make you feel better later this month  PS plus members will be able to vote on  one game for the program's March lineup  action Hank assault Android cactus and  broforce are all up for grabs which one  sounds good to you action Hank is a Time  Trial racing game assault Android cactus  as a twin stick shooter and broforce is  a side-scroller so you've got plenty of  options the poll opens februari 9th and  you can vote with the vote to play hub  on your ps4 you can get there through  the PSN store the PS plus hub and the  what's new section this isn't the first  time Sonia's let us vote on PS Plus  games grow home beat out zombie Vikings  and our mellow last August and the games  that didn't win ended up going on sale  maybe that'll happen this time to  whatever sony announces we'll tell you  all about it on gamespot  you